hi i'm dr morgan levine i'm a professor
who specializes in biology of aging
today i'll be answering your questions
from twitter this is aging support
[Music]
first up
bamabrat74 why does the aging process
have to be so dang painful over our
lifespans we have a lot of biological
molecular changes that accumulate in our
bodies and ultimately this makes our
bodies function less ideally and causes
a lot of these manifestations we see
with aging the aches the pains the
chronic diseases however in aging
science we actually think that we can
disentangle chronological time from
biological aging so chronological age is
what it says on your driver's license
however this is different from what we
call biological age which is really
measuring the state of the organism we
might say that even though you're
chronologically 50 years old you have a
biological state that actually resembles
someone who's more like a 60 year old
and what that means is we can actually
slow the rate at which these changes
accumulate or maybe even reverse them
and go back to a better functioning
state and with that we would actually
give people more years of life without
the painful parts of aging all right
next up from wild child
my head hurts so bad
why are hangovers getting worse as we
age science doesn't have an answer for
this and actually a lot of scientists
think that it's just that you have poor
recall of what your hangovers used to be
and actually there is no evidence that
hangovers get worse necessarily as we
age and you might just be forgetting how
bad they were when you were younger this
could also be in terms of childbirth why
women might actually be more willing to
have a kid again because they don't
remember how shitty it was to give birth
the first time next up jehan asks why do
we age why do we grow old and die and
how does the world really work this is a
fundamental question in biology i think
of it as up there with what is life it's
actually why i got really interested in
this field as a whole so an aging system
is what we call a very complex system
you have to have all your molecules and
cells in a very particular pattern to
support aging so almost i like to use
the analogy of the sand art you can lay
out these different things in a very
specific manner and when it comes to
life if you don't have that exact
pattern you don't have life the problem
is that it's hard to maintain this so
with any biochemical reaction that your
body undergoes you can get a slight
shift and over time these accumulate in
your system and we think that these are
why you're manifesting as aging because
you develop a state that is less
compatible with life than you originally
had next up eleanor shiki asked how much
of aging is genetic is longevity
heritable the good news is it isn't that
heritable we actually think that only
about 10 to maybe 20 percent of your
lifespan is dictated by your genes and
this is good news because it actually
means we have a lot more control over
how fast we're aging all right next up a
question from meg shigap can the aging
process stop the science doesn't say
that it can't happen but we're not close
to doing this we are close to showing
that we can slow the aging process there
is even some evidence that we can
reverse aging in some degree especially
in cells you can take cells from someone
who is let's say 65 years old and
convert them back to a cell that
actually looks like an embryonic stem
cell so we do think we have some power
to change aging but to take an entire
person stop the aging process altogether
and hold them frozen at that age forever
i think is probably a little farfetched
katrina dr selick asks tell me then
without saying anything misogynistic how
do men and women age differently even
though we might not be doing quite as
well in terms of the pay gap we're
actually doing better than men in terms
of the longevity gap women tend to live
about four and a half years longer than
men when you look at the world
population and even more than that if we
look at centenarians so these are people
who live to at least age 100 women make
up 83 of that population but
unfortunately it's actually not all good
news so there are definitely sex
differences in terms of kind of how we
age so women tend to be much more at
risk for things like frailty and for
diseases like alzheimer's disease and
osteoporosis so even though we might
live longer we do tend to suffer more
for some of these debilitating
conditions so next up from jhans3 i've
been plant-based for a minute but last
week i ate meat and i feel my absolute
best right now like how and why lol
what is the secret to longevity laughing
my ass off actually longevity science
says plant-based diet is probably the
best diet there's a lot of evidence from
both epidemiological which is the
science when you actually look at
populations as well as some more
emerging clinical trials that suggest
that a diet rich in mostly plant-based
foods can actually extend your lifespan
and prevent disease next up from sabaita
ramen what are the barriers to figuring
out biomarkers or hallmarks to aging is
it that no one else has focused in on it
too much or lack of funding and people
believing in it i feel a little hurt by
this question because this is what i
work on and i work really hard on it so
i don't think this is just for lack of
effort but this is actually a really
complex difficult thing to figure out in
terms of actually developing biomarkers
of aging or hallmarks of aging we have
to first be able to actually measure
these changes which is hard in and of
itself but even after we can measure it
we have tons and tons of data imagine
millions or billions of variables that
we can actually have to put together to
identify patterns so this isn't just
some easy feat that oh you just need to
look in a cell and figure out what
happens with age because the aging
process is so multifactorial so many
things happen we actually have to use a
lot of computer science and machine
learning coupled with molecular biology
to really figure out not just what's
going on but what things are actually
causing or driving the aging process
from pretty matty does the aging process
slow down in space
asking for a friend
there was a twin study uh with actually
the kelly twins who actually looked when
one stayed on earth and one went to
space what happened to them in
comparison to their aging and
unfortunately they actually found that
going into space seemed to accelerate a
lot of these hallmarks of aging are
things that we associate with the aging
process so we know that there's
gravitational time dilation so actually
it would slow down the closer you are to
earth but there's also
time dilation in terms of the speed at
which you're traveling so if you're
traveling faster time slows down it's
kind of counter balanced so it's hard to
say it depends on what you're doing in
space kennick edge asked is healthspan
like lifespan most of us know what
lifespan is it's basically how long
you're alive but a lot of people haven't
heard this term healthspan and really
what we use the term houseband to mean
is the amount of time you're alive
without disease or without some
age-related functional impairment so
even though health span and lifespan are
linked we think if you can extend your
health span you'll probably also live
longer there are actually two different
things and healthspan is more the part
we care about we don't all want to just
have more and more years in a kind of
more debilitated disease state we want
to have more healthy ears so this is the
part that aging research is trying to
target next up we have a question from
amy harman sciency people have there
been some definitive debunking and or
validation of blue zones do centenarians
in fact cluster there or no so for those
of you who don't know blue zones are
these places throughout the world where
they tend to have an enrichment of
people who survive to age 100. they tend
to be like longevity hot spots there
have not been debunking of blue zones
statistics don't lie longer-lived people
do live in these places but the reason
that they're longer lived is still
debatable so a lot of people speculate
that they have really good healthy
lifestyles they tend to be people who
eat more plant-based diet have really
active lifestyles and less stress but
again this is from looking at
populations these aren't randomized
controlled trials where we pick a set of
people we make them live in these places
and we see how long they live next up
from carly solstice does the aging
process just go to warp speed as you
approach 40. i feel like my gray hairs
have quadrupled and my wrinkles madly
increase in just the last few months
what we see in the aging process does
seem to increase exponentially later in
life things like graying of hair
wrinkles the onset of different diseases
but actually what's underlying that in
the biological aging process all these
molecular and cellular changes that we
think are actually the root causes of
those manifestations happen much earlier
in life however it takes time for those
to accumulate before we actually see
them on our skin in our hair or feel
them in our bodies and that's why it
actually feels like the aging process is
really accelerating towards the end of
life but actually a lot of the changes
happen much earlier next up we have a
question from cyrira is aging a disease
my view on it is that i don't like the
definition of disease when we think of
chronic disease things like diabetes or
heart disease these are not binary
states you have it or you don't these
are continuous processes they're things
that lie on a continuum you can be more
sick or less sick and actually rather
than saying aging is disease i would
argue that most of these chronic
diseases are just manifestations of
aging so i would actually flip it around
so next up from kaiser9798
i'm getting old
why do all my joints hurt now i didn't
do nothing to warrant the pain so
unfortunately kaiser this is something
that's gonna happen to all of us we are
all constantly getting older we're all
aging there are various reasons why your
joints might start hurting with age so
you can actually lose some of the
lubrication between joints people can
also develop things called
osteoarthritis where you actually lose
cartilage and you have more kind of bone
on bone we also lose strength in terms
of our ligaments and tendons and muscles
that just make everything kind of not
work as well and start aching over time
so next up we have a question from
natalie marmion is 45 the new 35 when it
comes to pregnancy how safe is it to
have a baby later in life people alive
today basically look like people from
the past who are only two and a half
years younger so we're looking better
but maybe not a whole decade better so
you could say 45 is the new 42 and a
half for the second question when it
comes to pregnancy how safe is it to
have a baby later in life the answer is
it probably depends on you the oldest
woman to ever give birth i believe was
just shy of 66 years old so for her she
was able to give birth to a healthy baby
and there's no issues however we don't
all age at the same rate and some of us
are able to reproduce much later in life
and some of us are going to age faster
and it's not healthy so ultimately it's
probably up to you and your doctor to
figure out what's best for you so next
up we have a question from dennis wurtz
cellular hallmarks of aging what are the
most predictive determinants of aging
the biochemical properties of cells or
biophysical ones for that i would argue
that actually the hallmark that i study
epigenetic modifications is probably the
most predictive as of right now so what
i mean by that is these are biochemical
modifications to your genome so one
might say okay they're biochemical
properties but actually they change the
biophysical structure of your dna so i
don't actually think we can group things
into either biochemical or biophysical
because in biology we learn form equals
functions so the physical structure will
affect the biochemical functioning of a
lot of these molecules next up a
question from 57th snowflake are you
aware of any studies on epigenetics and
the impact on longevity and if so what
impacts have been seen yes i'm aware of
these these are actually what my lab
focuses on day in and day out we study
the epigenetics of aging so what i mean
by that is the epigenetics are changes
so these are chemical modifications to
the dna without changing the sequence
and the exciting thing about epigenetics
is even though every cell in your body
has essentially the same dna your
epigenetics is what gives cells their
identity it's what makes a skin cell
different from a brain cell the
interesting thing is it also is what
makes a young cell different from an old
cell so we actually see specific
epigenetic changes so these chemical
changes that occur as a function of age
we can measure them and we can actually
use that information to infer something
about how quickly someone's aging and
this tells us something about the
probability that they're going to die in
the next 10 or 20 years and also the
probability that they're going to
develop various chronic diseases of
aging so next up from stormy leather new
york are there any anti-aging remedies
for hands because that's what's aging on
me the fastest my hands look 80.
probably not i would recommend sunscreen
next up a question from hike shannon
what is senescence this is actually the
term people used to use instead of aging
so we called it senescence more recently
people have actually started to study
something called cellular senescence and
what cellular senescence is is when a
cell undergoes some stress or has
reached the end of its lifespan it'll
actually transition to what we call a
senescent cell which means it's no
longer dividing but you can't kill it so
it doesn't have this what we call
apoptosis or this selective cell suicide
but the issue is that these cells
accumulate in our bodies as we age and
they actually have a really damaging
profile so they're excreting all of
these pro-inflammatory factors that can
damage the nearby cells and cause a lot
of tissue inflammation and so people in
the aging field have actually been
trying to target senescent cells to try
and remove them from aging tissues
thinking that this will restore some
anti-aging benefits so next up from
ethan j weiss is it true that calorie
restriction does well exercise does not
increase lifespan in mice if so why and
is that interesting actually there's
evidence now looking at different mouse
strains so these are mice with different
genetic backgrounds but actually showing
calorie restriction doesn't work quite
as well in all of them and some of them
they actually live shorter when they
restrict their calories in terms of
exercise i actually don't think that
there's good evidence that exercise is
not beneficial there was a study that
showed that there was a very limited
increase in lifespan for the exercise
mice for sedentary mice but the
important thing in that study is they
showed there was an increase in health
span which ultimately to me is the more
important thing all right next up b
dolan sfr asked what are the
neurological effects of excessive
consumption of the modern american diet
over the lifespan of an adult male how
many 60s and 70s babies are experiencing
pre-diabetic irritability and
accelerated brain aging due to a
lifetime of eating garbage the american
diet is and it's not good for the
aging process and we actually need to
change our dietary habits if we want to
live longer healthier lives and this can
be even more problematic for people who
have genetic predispositions to some of
these diseases of aging so you can
imagine the average american diet which
is basically the mcdonald's diet could
be really problematic to someone whose
body is actually not doing quite so well
in this area and finally from dr roy p s
medical science has made great strides
and thus longevity and life expectancy
has increased significantly major
pitfalls has been the exponential rise
in dementia cognitive impairment and
alzheimer's is there anything to rejoice
these conditions are worse than death so
ideally what we would want is not for
people to spend 60 years disease free
then develop a disease and then you keep
them alive for another 40 years we
actually want them to stay disease free
for let's say 95 years maybe develop a
disease and then you only have five
years with that disease so this is what
we call health span extension rather
than just lifespan extension and is
really what we need to work towards all
right so that's it for now thank you so
much for your questions i think they
were great ones and i hope you guys
learned something